[Musica]
mi viene in mente una domanda Qual è il
maggior vantaggio della
tecnologia ho provato a dare una
risposta un aumento della produttività
Connesso con un risparmio del tempo Cioè
riesco a fare più cose nel la stessa
unità di tempo oppure riesco a fare
delle cose che prima non ero in grado di
compiere e di fare tutto questo grazie
alla tecnologia e quali sono gli esempi
che ci vengono in mente per esempio le
mappe qualche anno fa ormai un po' di
anni fa prendevamo la nostra mappa di
carta la nostra matita segnavamo Magari
il punto di partenza il punto di arrivo
provavamo a indovinare le le strade per
raggiungerlo e non sapevamo se c'era
traffico se c'erano ostacoli oggi noi
digitiamo una
destinazione ci viene presentato subito
il tempo di percorrenza presunto se ci
sono dei rallentamenti la quantità di
traffico alcune applicazioni Addirittura
il carburante che utilizziamo e poi la
mail prendere la vecchia lettera di
carta forse era un po' più romantico
andare a comprare i francobolli
scriverla in bella calligrafia
imbar spedirla aspettare che
raggiungesse il nostro destinatario I
nostri destinatari oggi con la posta
elettronica Oggi anche qui già da
qualche anno non è più così il nostro
messaggio la nostra comunicazione arriva
direttamente al
destinatario si è perso Forse un po' di
romanticismo Ma sicuramente abbiamo
guadagnato in tempo e poi pagamenti non
più vecchie banconote usurate di carta
ma prima le carte di credito e bancomat
poi sugli Smartphone e e addirittura
delle applicazioni che permettono di
pagare direttamente dallo smartphone
addirittura senza aver collegato la
carta di credito nel telefono ma è tutto
bello questo un'altra domanda Quante
applicazioni inutilizzate abbiamo nei
nostri smartphone personalmente un po'
le cosiddette Zombie app cioè quelle
applicazioni che magari un amico un
vicino conoscente ci ha consigliato
abbiamo scaricato e le abbiamo
utilizzate magari una volta sola oppure
neanche quella proprio non l'abbiamo mai
utilizzata e queste applicazioni che
cosa fanno il nostro telefono intanto
prendono prendono i dati come tutte le
applicazioni specialmente quelle
gratuite No perché il pagamento sono i
dati non sono magari non sono i soldi
poi consumano risorse perché consumano
spazio nel nostro telefono e certe volte
addirittura consumano connessione con
consumano banda No addirittura si
collegano online e quindi questo non è
un gran vantaggio e per quanto riguarda
la la l'aspetto professionale cioè
l'aspetto delle aziende EB Beh da una
ricerca di sn2 se vince che le aziende
utilizzano il 56% delle licenze a loro
disposizione e il 44% va in spazzatura
Che cosa vuol dire questo che comprano
100 software e ne utilizzano 56 oppure
comprano un numero di software e ne
utilizzano solo una parte poco più della
metà questo Cosa significa significa
di workflow
aziendali qualche anno fa un ricercatore
americano Scott brinker con il suo team
di ricerca in maniera molto empirica
molto artigianale se vogliamo si è messo
a mappare i software di marketing
presenti sul mercato marketing vuol dire
un po' tutto che fanno invio di email
social media Digital marketing in senso
un po' lato e ne aveva trovati 150 era
il
2011 nel
2023 ha evoluto il suo modo di il suo
metodo di ricerca con sistemi
chiaramente più moderni ma i software
mappati sono più di 11.000 e cosa vuol
dire questo vuol dire innanzitutto che
chiaramente c'è stata una crescita
vertiginosa No in questi anni ma per il
consumatore chiaramente è un bene più
concorrenza più
offerta più
qualità prezzi più bassi naturalmente
però che cosa Che cosa succede come
facciamo a orientare la nostra scelta e
qui parliamo di aziende quindi di
software per l'uso professionale ma
anche per un uso personale diciamo così
o anche ludico individuale a orientarsi
in questa mappa Non è semplice per
niente e quindi e quindi che cosa c'è
c'è un paradosso No il paradosso è che
utilizziamo il software per risparmiare
il tempo però poi questo tempo alla fine
Lo perdiamo
in selezione perché sono tantissimi
quale scelgo tra i tanti che abbiamo
visto prima informazione perché devo
imparare a utilizzare questi software
dobbiamo imparare a gestirli questi
software e se siamo parte di un team di
lavoro dobbiamo insegnarli a qualc un
altro fare formazione Condividere queste
conoscenze sui software e poi
sostituzione Perché molte di Quelle
aziende che abbiamo visto sono delle
startup Le startup hanno un Altissimo
tasso di vitalità ma anche un alto tasso
di mortalità quindi molti di questi
software magari chiudono e se io noi
proviamo a impostare il nostro business
su uno di questi che poi dopo un mese
chiude Dobbiamo dobbiamo essere pronti E
allora proviamo a
identificare Come come far fronte a
tutto ciò non esiste la formula magica
eh Vi do una brutta notizia però
Esistono delle linee guida che davvero
ci possono aiutare a orientarci e e
davvero aumentare la produttività
risparmiando il tempo con i software con
i tool con questi strumenti La prima è
dare un'occhiata sostanzialmente alle
esigenze aziendali e anche qui aziendali
ma anche personali quindi facendo
un'analisi di ciò che abbiamo già quel
44% di prima no magari c'è qualcosa che
ci serve lo cerchiamo ma ce lo abbiamo
già nel nostro parco software che ormai
è abbastanza ampio e fare un'analisi
oggettiva razionale se vogliamo Laica
del del nostro parco software poi andare
provare a immaginarci quello che vorremo
cioè che quello che ci piacerebbe avere
o ci piacerebbe con software
Fae Dopodiché dopo che abbiamo queste
due linee diciamo così di Orizzonte
facciamo un'analisi dei costi benefici
vale la pena vale la pena buttar via
questo 44% magari anche l'altro 56 per
sostituirlo con un qualche cosa che
ancora non conosciamo in profondità Non
lo so Forse sì forse no poi l'altra
questione è andare a cercare valutare le
opzioni possibili la prima cosa è
guardare le recensioni online dei
software che abbiamo e che magari
vogliamo prendere la seconda è una
stringa di ricerca per i motori di
ricerca molto molto semplice alternativa
più e si può riempire come vogliamo
economica
performante semplice da usare
a nome di un software famoso di un
software che avete o di un software che
che fa una cosa complementare a quello
che vorreste Word Excel e riempite voi e
poi alla fine blog di settore cioè
andare a cercare quei contenuti onl che
Però sono prodotti da blog di settore
Quindi da diciamo così esperti verticali
sulla materia che magari ne sanno un po'
di più di di quello che potete trovare
normalmente sui motori di
ricerca alla fine dobbiamo anche cercare
di capire questi Software Come si
parlano tra loro cioè andare a cercare
le integrazioni fra questi sistemi e fra
queste piattaforme è un trend anche
questo in grande crescita cioè le
software House cercano di rendere il più
possibile integrata la propria
piattaforma con altri
sistemi certe volte concorrenti questo
avviene raramente e spesso complementari
quindi dobbiamo andare a cercare le
integrazioni sui software anche che
abbiamo già che possediamo già Con che
cosa si integrano questi software che
abbiamo già e queste integrazioni
possono essere sia Native Cioè
direttamente inserite nel sistema sia ci
possono essere dei software di
Automation cioè dei software che mettono
in collegamento due sistemi due
piattaforme uno dei più famosi è un
acronimo di Se accade questo Allora fai
quello quindi per esempio Ricevo una
mail da un mittente che ha un allegato e
io dico al software se ricevo una mail
da questo mittente con allegato Allora
salva l'allegato in una cartella in
Cloud o dove voglio non farò più
niente in autonomia il software farà
questa attività e salverà questo questo
allegato direttamente nel cloud
e poi testare la curiosità la la la
voglia di di di imparare e di mettersi
in gioco di testare le nuove soluzioni
cioè ogni nuova soluzione deve essere
Calata e provata direttamente sulla
realtà aziendale o personale quindi
dobbiamo andare a sporcarsi le mani un
po' no andare a provare questi software
fare degli errori fare dei test
analizzare quello che è successo e poi
magari ricominciare e magari buttare
anche via tutto il il percorso che
abbiamo fatto per andare a cercare
un'altra
piattaforma di questo tipo Insomma alla
fine alla fine delle fini ci sono c'è un
mondo fuori c'è un mondo di piattaforme
ha dato tutte le tasche a tutte le
realtà Aziendali e personali quindi
cercate onl ce ne sono tantissimi
provateli provateli provateli just it
[Applauso]
Grazie